my good buddy rece Davis back here on
the show how are you Rhys I'm doing
great how are you I'm good
you know it's it's interesting how
things have kind of gotten shaken up in
the Western Conference a little bit
since the since the end of the NBA
Finals with Anthony Davis going to the
Lakers and obviously Mike Conley now
going to the Jazz and draft choices are
being used in all of this I'm wondering
what you're hearing about potential more
trades going down before tomorrow night
Rhys I think that a lot of teams are
really still trying to be active I was
talking to watch just a little while ago
and Bobby marks as well and the Lakers
are trying to find more teams to include
in that deal with the pelicans which
can't be finalized until July 6 that's
another issue for another discussion I
guess but you know they're still trying
to clear out some more salary cap space
to pursue a third max free agent
potentially you know to try to reshape
their roster to find the complementary
pieces to LeBron and AD I think that the
pelicans have been very aggressive in
trying to auction that number for
overall pick that they are getting from
the Lakers on Thursday night so I still
think there's a lot of a lot of movement
to come and obviously Memphis has now
completely declared what we pretty much
already knew by creating Mike Conley
that they are going with John Moran the
second spot and though the Knicks have
been trying to throw a little bit of a
smoke screen there than having Darius
garland work him out the point guards
badvel I believe they'll end up taking
Archie Barrett from Duke in their spot
well as you know New Yorker sports fans
don't really have their heads on
straight facts straight
on draft nights in any sport pretty much
although you can't blame them for kind
of wondering who kristaps porzingis was
a couple years ago if the Knicks take
Darius garland out of Vanderbilt instead
of RJ Barrett out of Duke third overall
that would be quite the moment in
Barclays Center for you rece Davis that
night I think it would and you know how
this rich we end up rooting for the
story that was very entertaining or sure
it would also I was met with some groans
and admittedly this was a bit hyper
bollocks I sort of went off in the
meeting yesterday and said you know if
I'm going to compare this to college
football says don't know that I
understand this fascination with the
Knicks in all the years I mean I get its
New York and it's different but every
year I've been doing the draft stories
and Knicks are going to get this guy's
going to get LeBron you're going to get
Katie they're getting him for getting
him they don't get anybody they don't
win I say to be pretty easy to put it in
college football terms to say that the
Knicks have the arrogance of Alabama and
the tradition of Vanderbilt you know so
it's you know it's been a long time just
Dave the butcher and you know so I don't
know it seems like a really important
time for them and there are people who
believe that you can build a winning
team around Archer Barrett he's a real
mature guy he's obviously highly skilled
in among freshman I think only four guys
at school more points and freshmen he
did you know guys like Chris Jackson and
Michael Beasley on that list so you know
he's a tremendous player and one day
perhaps next could recapture some of
that elusive glory behind you know it's
amazing Reese when you think about it
cuz you just brought up again obviously
Moran Co and second overall to Memphis
the Conley trade the Anthony Davis trade
might not have happened the way that
they happen at all if it wasn't though
the lottery I mean that was a huge night
for obviously the pelicans being able to
take Zion tomorrow night and then
collecting the fourth overall selection
for the Lakers which was huge for them
to get up there and the fact that the
Knicks were third and not first overall
means New Orleans did what they did for
Anthony Davis and then the Conley trade
might not happen if they if Memphis
didn't have the number two overall pick
in their back pocket for tomorrow night
it's amazing yeah absolutely and then
the whole thing was aimed as you know
that you can keep rotating and trying to
maintain the integrity of the regular
season but the way that played out it
certainly did and already it had a huge
impact on the direction the teams are
taking and I think really that the draft
just sort of raises the curtain on
what's going to be the next few weeks to
a month or so sort of reshaping the
balance of power in the NBA
given the
fact that the West is suddenly open with
the injuries to Durant and klay Thompson
that will you know if Durant even
chooses to come back to go on state and
and clay as well but you know they're
not going to be playing for the Warriors
one way or the other for the majority if
not all of the season next year so it's
sort of changed thinking a little bit
and you have the drama in Houston has it
been overstated can Paul and harden
coexist and if so can they elevate it to
the point where they can finally get to
the championship round the finals it
there's a lot there's a lot out there
teams have to make decisions about
trying to jump through this this window
of opportunity that has been created to
some degree by free agency until larger
degree by the unfortunate injuries to
grant Thompson
rece Davis of ESPN getting ready to host
the NBA draft tomorrow night
from New York City right here on the
Rich Eisen show I'll tell you what you
brought up the the Rockets story that
Yahoo broke yesterday that that Paul and
hardens relationship are as
unsalvageable as the word that was used
by an unnamed source I'll tell you what
when you look at Chris Paul's salary
they better get that guy from the office
that actor from the office to pull a
State Farm sort of bringing everybody
together because I don't know how Chris
Paul gets dealt if he has in fact even
though he did post on a bleacher report
Instagram feed that that this is not
true it's news to him he said that he's
always demanded a trade what are you
hearing about all of this in New York
City day before the draft Reese I think
they're I think most of our guys believe
that you know certainly it's tense but
I'm not sure that they are quite ready
to say to the level of being
unsalvageable but I think the most
important thing is probably what you
just brought up it's going to be hard to
find somebody not the Chris Paul isn't
or hasn't been a great player but you
have to find you have to find the right
team that would be willing to take on
that type of salary and believe that
he's the guy that could perhaps get that
particular team you know over the hump
and then to the file
a chance win championship I mean you
know so that market would be very small
so I think the best case scenario for
Houston if they can is to try you know
is to try to make that work but as I
mentioned early if this if this is your
opportunity and it has in fact reached a
level that you not believe it can be
fixed and there's been you know tensions
with the front office of Mike D'Antoni
in the contract negotiations there may
be this is a time you make a bold move
and and if you can find a partner it's
really easy to say well let's try this
guy somebody else but with the salary
cap gold even as high as the salary cap
is right now you have to find not only
willing partners the partners who are
able to make it work financially so
you've got your hands full Reese
tomorrow night as you you know did the
NFL Draft at least when trades are made
between teams right when Josh Rosen was
acquired by the Dolphins the Cardinals
made the pick in the dolphin spot right
then and there and it was announced that
that player was going to the Cardinals
with the NBA I mean it's possible that
the Lakers choose fourth overall
tomorrow night and that the Jazz choose
23rd overall tomorrow night for
respectively New Orleans or some other
team fourth overall and Montes for Utah
four for Memphis tomorrow night right I
mean and you've got explain all this at
that time yeah that's going to happen
and that's it can't be like the the
Anthony Davis deal can't be consummated
or completed or official until the new
year starts oh it can't be do i sick you
know there's also that cause if they
pushed it back to the 30th there could
be more cap room for somebody to a
center for the pelicans and a lot of
things that are way down in the week the
one thing that I did I hope and this is
a I had someone explain this to me not
too long ago this is a collective
bargaining issue and the situation is if
they were to open it up and make it the
way it should be which is the way the
NFL does it I think the thought is it
would open other issues in the CBA that
they're not will that they don't want to
do yet hopefully what's going to happen
in the future is that the new
year will start before the draft
therefore you can you can do exactly as
they do in the NFL and when the trade is
made like with Rosen's a team where the
players going actually makes a selection
because it's going to be a weird thing
when the Lakers pick fourth overall as
one of the things I asked I said well we
aren't always not going to the Lakers is
does the guy still get the hat and you
know I guess you guys I know like the
famed Eli Manning holding up the San
Diego Chargers Jersey looking like he
just swallowed a whole bottle of castor
oil to use I guess an old-school phrase
I mean that's a rarity in the NFL these
days but it's so difficult to keep heads
or tails so how would that work Reese in
terms of newly gear happens before the
draft would they move the draft into
July because or and/or you say no I what
would happen I look I'm yeah I'm sort of
I'm speculating here and throwing out my
opinion what I would like to see and I
think will be better for our grass and
maybe they'll say hey look that's good
for us broadcast but not our business
right yes it would be great if the new
you know what the new lead year started
say after the finals or whatever and you
know if you can after the finals you
kept the draft about the same time you
said okay now maybe you can't pursue
free agents until the you know the July
1st date which they've always had but in
terms of what the finances are and
whether cranes will work here's the date
before the drafting you know because
they were the Lakers and pelicans would
like to find another team or teams to
add another layer to this to give the
Lakers some more cap space but even so
they have the framework of the deal they
can do the deal as it is on July 6 they
would like to add something else but my
understanding is is that you know they
can the deal can be done as it is now
right what I'd like to see is for the
new league year to start so that we can
finish this and that the deal can be
done and that we know and thicknesses
pelicans will pick 1st and 4th unless
they you know unless they trade the pick
so hopefully that's what will happen but
again I'm speaking completely selfishly
for the good of
or of allograft no look Maurice I mean
obviously a draft being viewed is is a
crucial PR element for any sport in any
in any league and you know I'm sure
there will be tons of fans tomorrow
night and that's gonna be your job in
real time to not only keep things afloat
with your analysts talking in the clock
running down
to basically say don't be confused by
that Laker hat on this young man's head
and you might not even be a pelican
either I mean so it's it's not right
it's not easy no you're right and that
is something that I'm I'm gonna have to
be very cognizant of and have everything
and tried to remind people you know this
pic is part of this proposed trade
that's the verbiage he likes receives
proposed killers okay
official so you know you'll continue to
continue to put that out there and
continue to remind them and I also
mentioned our people I think that we
need to have that constantly in graphic
support as well so that when people see
you know whoever whoever goes for you
know Garrett Culver DeAndre hunter
Garland or Kobe why the river might be
you know in there putting on a Laker
head we can graphics support verbal
support cosplay he's not going to be
able you know that kind of not a Lakers
you say at the bottom not a Laker we
don't know where he's going
the guy sentimental type feel you work
your whole lives you have this great
moment right right and you get drafted
and you're you're a lottery pick you're
in the first round you know you're not
going to this team the boy you're going
dreamt of putting on that hat and you're
putting on hats it's not going to be
your team you know it sort of if I'm not
mistaken Rhys you've had in the last
couple years at some point somebody
talking about how what it meant to him
to be drafted by that team and got
really emotional or told a story or
they'd rooted for this team and at that
point they were being traded to another
team bridges right yeah
McHale bridges last year from Villanova
picked by the Sixers race to design and
you know he wouldn't
he was you know he heard Philadelphia
guy and you know played it going over
and you know was very excited about it
and then it you know he was part of the
deal and you know what that's part of
the business of and I feel bad you know
it's not all about sentiment but uh ya
know you know with his situation they
were still working on to deal with this
when the deals already done you know
you'd like to see and be able to have
its moment proper attire all the ways
you plays you rightly point out may be
picked by the Lakers for the pelicans
and still not wind up a pelican either
so there's life in it might be an
example of which it's an unavoidable
situation by the way that verbatim will
not fit at the bottom of the screen
tomorrow night race maybe on a scroll
like what you just said might be you
could scroll every last word all 20 of
those words great broadcast resaw be
watching rece davis a go for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app